bueno los últimos días se ha habido
protestas en Shanghai belgin uhants en
show ulumucci son media docena escasas
Aún si recordemos que este país tiene la
quinta parte de la población mundial
pero cada vez son más y más acentuadas y
además revelan un hartazgo latente y
tiene un efecto contagio que inquieta Un
gobierno que es sacraliza la estabilidad
social lo que piden los manifestantes es
una batería de reclamaciones muy
heterodoxa yo estuve en las potestas de
anoche en el río liamma aquí en Pekín y
lo único claro es que hay un
comprensible hartazgo de la política de
cero covid Después de tres años pide en
el fin de los confinamientos y el
regreso a la vida normal sobre todo lo
demás Hay más dudas también se canta el
himno nacional también la internacional
socialista se escuchan unas pocas
reclamaciones de Estado de derecho y
libertad de expresión Bueno de hecho es
ya icónico el folio en blanco que llevan
algunos para denunciar la censura Pero
insisto son protestas en las que manda
la pulsación y que tienen que ver mucho
más con el cansancio de los
confinamientos que con una motivación
política
además os habló de Por qué china no
puede permitirse una apertura total de
su sociedad como ya lo hacen casi todos
los países del mundo que optaron por
simplemente convivir con el virus esto
nos dijo
bueno la política de China se suele
explicar como Un capricho del gobierno
ajeno a la ciencia o al sentido como no
lo es todos los estudios científicos
tanto chinos como extranjeros alertan de
que si el país se abre como occidente
habrá un aluvión de contagios que
devastará los hospitales y que provocará
entre uno y dos millones de muertos y
recordemos que hasta ahora no se han
superado las 6.000 muertes es decir son
cifras inasumibles lo que explica este
hecho diferencial chino es por un lado
la baja vacunación entre ancianos y por
el otro la precaria red sanitaria rural
Y ninguno de los dos problemas tiene una
solución fácil así que ese es el debate
normalizar el país y dejar que la
economía fluya de nuevo o asumir una
mortandad enorme el gobierno ha repetido
que mantendrá el acerokovic mientras las
ventajas superan a los inconvenientes y
El veredicto parecía claro hasta ahora
porque tanto el deterioro de la economía
como el hartazgo social eran manejables
ahora lo segundo ya no está tan claro
Hay un riesgo claro de que las protestas
extiendan aún más Y quizá ha llegado el
momento de realizar un nuevo cálculo yo
creo que lo único seguro es que con cero
covid o sin ella los próximos meses van
a ser muy complejos y muy difíciles aquí
en China